how important is it for you to have a
strong personal connection to the
material that you're writing oh I think
it's really important you know I think
it's it's so important you know if
you're writing something for you like a
play and stage play or something that's
personal
obviously absolutely but even on
something that's not particularly about
you or something of your life and your
concern you have to find your way into
it and you have to find your way how do
you connect to it you are writing what
makes you the the unique writer of any
any story or any script is your
perspective and what you bring to it if
if you and I were to write the same
script we bring bring we might get to
the same end goal and the story might
not be the similar but the how we get
there would be very different because
we'd be bringing our own experiences to
it and our own views of things and and
other people's views of things that
we've seen you know so yeah I think that
being able to connect define stories
that you connect with are fine create
connections that you relate to because
it becomes very honest that way and so
that's okay whether it's comedy or drama
honesty and real experiences and we'd
like we've talked about earlier the
things that you overhear people saying
in the supermarket that you can use
because that moved you or made you laugh
and you can use that that's your you
know those connections are really really
critical I think to making to make for
good writing and good stories you know
you don't have to but I definitely think
it's a big help why did you begin
writing ah that's a good question um you
know I think I started writing like when
I started writing you know my very first
writing that I did was I wrote movie
reviews for the high school newspaper
and I think part of it was there was a
certain escape factor to it back then I
mean certainly movies were a bit of an
escape and writing about them was like I
just I had a lot of thoughts about them
you know I loved movies and I read a lot
of film criticism as a kid and and it
was really you know a big part of my
world and it meant a lot to me it was
like well I want to do that I can write
that and I've read so much I've seen so
many movies I can take it it's fun let
me take a crack at and it was fun and I
and I'd like being able to share
opinions and get conversations going
about things and hear people had
different opinions than mine and and all
of that and it was just again I just
love craft writing the words and
crafting you know crafting the words and
it just sort of evolved you know and
I've always loved movies
Theatre and and and television and and
stories and books and telling stories
and reading stories and all of that so
at a certain point you know if you want
to be part of that you either are on one
side of it or another so I started off
as a publicist promoting other people's
movies and being able to talk about
other people's movies writing and
selling other people's movies but then
at a certain point I realized I wanted
to start telling those stories I wanted
to be the one to create those movies in
those stories that's sort of sort of
speaking to me much more than being on
the other side of the table as I call it
so yeah it's just sort of evolved you
know and and and also it's it ultimately
is something that I think I have you
know more of a talent at than other
things so you know you go where you you
have the most talent most ability to
remember the defining moment when you
said I think I want to move on from the
publicist yes exactly I was there I
could like it was yesterday
my boss was leaving to go on a trip for
three weeks and she said to me you know
they want you to sign a contract here
and because I was a place where I think
they were going to promote me to it like
give me a little bit of a promotion or
whatever some title promotion and and
give me some new duties or something and
she said so they want you to sign a
contract as well how long is the
contract portion well it's a six-year
contract it's two years two years in two
years and and and she says so while I'm
away read it take a look at it and then
sign it and when I come back I'll sign
it and you know we'll move forward and
when she was gone I was like I can't
sign that contract and I just realized I
didn't want to be there I just I I just
I it just wasn't right for me you know
it was a time jacket job at the time and
you know you always you know was like
very political and and all of that and
not that you know screenwriting doesn't
have its own politics and all of that
but I don't know it just I just felt it
was there was something I just wasn't
accomplishing what I really wanted felt
I wanted to it at a really young age I
just still wasn't like I just felt like
it wasn't this wasn't where I needed to
be you know even though I was doing well
with it it wasn't where I needed to be
and my father was visiting me around
that time my father passed away last
year but he he was a very bottom line
kind of
- kind of guy very meeting potatoes and
not a showbiz guy at all and but I was
supported what I did but just didn't
have a great sense of it and he said to
me I said you know dad they want me to
sign a contract
anything I should do he goes well do you
want to stay there and I said I don't
and then he said well then you should
leave I said well I can't leave this job
this is a job that people aspire to
you know I but what if you know is what
do you want to do I said I actually want
to write I want to write you know movies
in television because then that's what
you should do I said well you know what
if it doesn't work out he says listen
you don't want to be my age and look
back and say I should have done it and
then it's too late
he says if that's what you have to do
you have to do it and I was like shocked
that he said that and not that I was
listening to him necessarily but it was
like it was coming from an interesting
place and I just thought about and I
said he's right I'm just gonna I'm not
gonna sign that contract and my boss
came back and she said so did you sign
the contract and I said no and she said
oh so you just didn't get to it yet I
said no I'm not signing that contract
and she said you're not signing the
contract and I said no I said I'm
leaving I'm gonna write for television
and I did and then I called my father
and I said dad I quit my job and he said
you did what how could you quit a job
like that who quits a job like that and
you know four years after that you know
he would say to me you know if you
stayed there you probably would've been
president of that place but I was just
so glad to be gone and it was a you know
good experience for certain things
certainly helped me in many many ways as
a writer and as a marketer of my
material but it was that was the time I
knew I had it had to move on and never
looked never looked back so when you got
your things together in a box or
whatever and left with did you feel a
weight had been I felt so great you know
when I was when I was saying goodbye to
people is really fine I don't mean to be
arrogant too bad or anything cuz it was
just it was not it was a difficult time
you know you know work wise and
personally at that time and I just I
kind of need it to go and I remember one
was one of one summer I worked with his
seed said to me you know what you're
doing is is so brave to leave and I said
no would it it would be more courageous
to stay you know meaning that like it
was tougher to stay than to go in a
certain respect but yet I knew I was
dying I I didn't realize what a you know
what a deep pool I would
would be I was diving into you know
becoming a writer I just it again like I
said I just was soft a mystic about it I
just felt I wasn't quite aware of the
difficulties of it you know and so to me
it was just like the thing to do staying
there would it would be more more
difficult but no I was I was happy to go
by the time I was I was done it's ready
do you think a lot of people do that in
Hollywood they stay in certain things
but they everybody in life stays often
stays and things that they're just not
happy with because sometimes they don't
know where to go you know I was very
very fortunate you know I I've always
had I kind of known what I wanted to do
I've had things that I'm passionate
about you know my work is my is my
enjoyment you know so I feel very very
fortunate with that but a lot of people
aren't happy in a job but they don't
really know what else they want to do
and I and I would never recommend
anybody just not be happy in something
and just up and leave without knowing
where they're going because it could
take a very long time to get another job
and you're always more valuable while
you're employed you know whatever you're
doing so yeah but I think there are
definitely people who are you know
living those you know just desperate in
those desperate situations but you know
I encourage people you know who really
aren't happy and what they do to find
your passion and to figure out a way to
make it a career if you can not
everything can be you know not
everything is that monetizable or that
you know realistic but you know work is
a big part of our lives and it really
helps if you if you can enjoy it
you